(gentle music)
Incoming bonus content.
I remember a Fever Pitch story.
I remember you literally hurting your back
falling off the green monster.
I did.
In Boston.
You came down, it's in the movie, went,
landed and you went like ugh.
I landed on my tailbone.
Yes.
That I had cracked during Charlie Angels Two
doing a stunt.
And then you had to run all the way
through Family Park to me.
And you were just so out of breath by the third take,
you were like.
(gasping)
(laughter)
Okay, I remember another story.
I remember flying on an airplane and we were flying to the,
the game, game seven of the world series.
The Red Sox and it was in St. Louis.
Yep.
And I was like, we were terrified,
but we were gonna get to shoot on the Fox Sports cameras
the ending of our film.
If they won they were gonna let us run down to home plate
and do a 360 kiss.
'Cause Fox had the cameras.
It was a Fox broadcast.
Yeah and we were making a Fox movie.
So we said can we borrow a couple cameras while we're,
so we, we're making a movie.
Because they're like you can't bring your movie cameras
to the game.
Yeah and we said just on one condition,
you can't show that Jimmy and Drew are at the game
on your broadcast.
Yeah.
Because that won't make any sense.
We're making a movie and no one,
cut to we're making out on the dugout or something,
and aired on the world series.
And everyone's like what?
Are they dating, what's going on?
Oh and my boyfriend at the time didn't know.
And didn't know we were doing that.
It's airing and he's like hey,
I got a bunch of great texts.
Fabi was in the Strokes and on tour
and I couldn't talk to him 'cause it was,
it was before cell phones.
Yeah.
And I hadn't got to him and he was like what's going on?
And I was like oh God.
It's for the movie.
The best thing ever.
We had so much fun.
And that was a little bit extra for you.
(gentle music)